Annie Vignola profite
des derniers jours avec
ses enfants, car la rentrée
scolaire s'annonce mouvementée.
Elle n'est pas certaine d'avoir
accès à un service d'autobus
pour ses deux aînés.
ANNIE VIGNOLA
- On espérait bien, en fait,
que les grands allaient pouvoir
prendre l'autobus, parce que
les garderies aussi c'est
compliqué, fait qu'on a deux
garderies différentes,
plus les écoles à manager
avec deux emplois. Ça va être
un beau casse-tête.
- 95 % des contrats
en  transport scolaire
sont arrivés à échéance
à la fin du mois de juin.
Ils tardent à être renouvelés
entre autres dans les régions
du Grand Montréal, de Lanaudière
et de la Montérégie.
Les négociations entre
la Fédération des transporteurs
par autobus et le ministère
de l'Éducation achoppent.
Les transporteurs demandent
une hausse de 25 % des tarifs.
LUC LAFRANCE, pdg, Fédération
des transporteurs par autobu
- Les règles budgétaires qui ont
été proposées, déposées
par le ministère de l'Éducation
en juin ne sont pas suffisantes
pour permettre auxeurs
de couvrir l'ensemble de leur
frais reliés à leurs opérations
et faire face aussi aux
fluctuations dues aux prix
du carburant ou des pièces,
ou de l'entretien.
- Conséq'impasse :
près de 300 000 élèves
pourraient ne pas avoir
de transport à la rentrée.
Le gouvernement reste confiant.
JONATHAN ROBERGE,
ministre de l'Éducation
- Il y avait beaucoup
de contrats qui arrivaient à
échéance au printemps dernier.
On le savait. Donc, on avait
obtenu des fonds supplémentaires
de la part de finance et trésor
au gouvernement, pour tenir
compte à l'inflation et au coût
plus élevé du diesel. Donc,
on a déposé des offres bonifiées
et les négociations avancent.
- De leur côté, les centres
de services scolaires assurent
aux parents que :
- Si ça a va être
un cadeau, mais on a déjà
des plans B, puis C, puis D.
- Il reste deux semaines
avant la rentrée des classes.
si le gouvernement
est convaincu que les contrats
seront signés d'ici là, avec
la pénurie de main-d'oeuvre
dans le secteur du transport
, les familles
ne sont pas à l'abri
d'autres perturbations.
Ici Charlotte Dumoulin,
Radio-Canada, Montréal